jacques chagnon qui à l'époque avait
lancé cette phrase qui est resté qu'on
accuse ou qu'on s'excuse on ne l'a
jamais accusé il n'y a pas eu de vraie
excuse encore parce qu'encore beaucoup
beaucoup de mystères guy ouellette
député indépendant de chamiers dit avec
monsieur ouellette bonsoir bonsoir
monsieur roy sus aux élèves dans un
livre que j'ai lu de la page 1 à la
dernière page de 300 quelques en fin de
semaine vous expliquer en long et en
large que finalement vous avez été dans
cette histoire rocambolesque le bouc
émissaire de l'upac
on vous accuse un an vous soupçonné
d'être l'auteur des fuites médiatiques
surtout sur l' enquête machu réel qui a
trait au financement du parti libéral du
québec et il était sûr que c'était voulu
entre guillemets le bandit oui mais je
vous dirais que vous l'avez lu monsieur
owens et 336 pages de faits qui sont à
ma connaissance je sais pas tout de
l'histoire vous savez le bureau des
enquêtes indépendantes en une autre
grosse partie se fait deux ans qu'ils
enquêtent duruz enquête indépendante
nous disent qu'il y en a encore pour
deux ans c'est ma partie les faits qui
sont à ma connaissance c'est ce que je
livre d'antoine 136 pages c'est mais on
quand vous racontez ces sept heures en
plus se réalise ou j'étais enfermé dans
une pièce avec deux policiers qui vous
pose des questions vous racontez pas
beaucoup par contre quelle question il
vous pose est-ce que ils sont convaincus
que vous êtes la personne qui fait
fuiter des grands bouts de l'enquète des
enquêtes de l'upac
ceux qui m'ont fait arrêter le savent
que je suis pas la bonne personne
les deux qui m'ont interrogé on les
aurait impliqué selon leurs dires la
veille ça servait les intérêts de ceux
qui avait fuité aux médias les
informations ils ont amené avec eux
d'autres enquêteurs de l'upac
je vous dirais que depuis l'opération de
plusieurs qui sont partis du pack qui a
probablement plusieurs procureurs de la
couronne au dpcp qui sont pas tellement
contents de la façon que ça s'est passé
il ya peut-être deux juges le juge
champoux et le juge chapdelaine a qui
ont été menés en bateau
probablement que aussi sont pas
tellement raconté au public même si elle
est là parce qu'elle est évidemment il
ya beaucoup de détails dans l'est mais
ils étaient convaincus à tort vous dites
vous aujourd'hui
mais il était convaincu que vous étiez
l'auteur principal des fuites à du pack
ceux qui m'ont interrogé non non ce que
qui l'ont interrogé il n'y avait pas
toutes les informations c'est un très
mal commencé parce que j'étais sous
filature la journée de l'arrestation et
il y avait même pas la bonne personne
n'y pensaient que j'étais avec ma
conjointe alors que j'étais en rendez
vous professionnel avec quelqu'un
d'autre ça commence très mal
un interrogatoire donc ça me disais que
il disait des questions qu'on nous avait
préparé et il y avait été il y avait
était entré dans ce dossier lors
probablement à leur corps défendant
mais messieurs la première qui est allé
en commission parlementaire
d'ailleurs c'est fascinant dans l'est
parce que vous la première ci à ne plus
inviter au même party là parce que c'est
vos chemins se sont vraiment éloignés
mais je reviens bac s mais sur la
fronière odile publiquement on va
trouver le bandit qui est responsable
des fuites qui nuisent aux enquêtes à
l'upac qu'on se souvient cda pleine page
journaux de jouer à montréal en trop on
avait les détails de l'enquète ma chérie
je repose ma question que si on allait
dans leur esprit
vous étiez responsable de ces fruits
glacés pour ceux qui s'est abattue sur
vous un cours ou comme seul j'étais un
des des personnes moi j'étais le
président de la commission des
institutions mais l'avenir nous aura
appris je dire la quête nous a appris
les mots après l'arrestation nous a
appris qu'il y avait autant que monsieur
lafleur était autant intéressé par
d'autres membres de la commission des
institutions
tous les autres membres de la commission
des institutions monsieur k est monsieur
bérubé monsieur bergeron
donc il y avait autant de ces personnes
lors vous avez lu attentivement le
chapitre iv monsieur roy et je le
mentionne moi je présidais la commission
des institutions
c'était la commission des institutions
qui demandait une reddition de comptes à
l'organisation du bac et le commissaire
vous n'avez pas la faire cette tradition
de compte là alors je kg en reste avec
nous lorsque votre hypothèse dans tout
le livre toulon du livre c'est de dire
que monsieur la première parce que vous
étiez un de ceux qui ne voulaient pas
qu'ils grossissent son pouvoir à du tac
vous étiez un de ceux qui devaient
scruter ce qu'ils faisaient à la
commission parlementaire
vous dites que dans son esprit vous êtes
devenu une cible puis ont voulu vous
abattre en faisant croire que vous
faisiez des fruits c'est ça je résume
vous avez totalement raison monsieur roy
en partant du moment où
y'a un timide les parlementaires qui
m'enlève de son chemin il ya plus un
parlementaire qui pose de questions a
dit pas depuis 2010 est ok mais les
frites là est ce que c'est vous qui
étiez responsable ou pas des flux mais
non c'est pas moi qui était responsable
des fuites
je les dis sous serment quand on est
allé témoigner dans une requête du
procès normandeau côté à québec devant
le juge perreault ok donc ils ont ils
ont monté un bateau contre vous dites
vous c'est votre tête
le problème qu'on a pu le monde du conte
à talant quête du pays qui vont enquêter
sur la quête sur vous surtout ça
s'arrête plus de finir cette enquête là
on est rendu à plus de 3 millions de
dollars mais le problème c'est que vous
avez pas non plus de preuve pour pour
comme sur la première soit pris dans un
coin avec ces accusations là vous faites
envers lui je fais pas d'accusations
monsieur au moins je rapporte des faits
qui sont à ma connaissance il ya 336
pages de faits qui sont à ma
connaissance il ya d'autres faits qui
sont à la connaissance du pays dont j'ai
pas connaissance et si ça peut
effectivement les aider je vous dirais
que depuis ce matin
il ya beaucoup c'est une autre raison du
livre depuis ce matin beaucoup de jeunes
qui se souviennent de certaines choses
qui vont amener d'autres éléments qui
vont appeler obéit pour lui permettre
d'entrer leur enquête et qui vont faire
en sorte qu' on ne va pas attendre deux
ans après les prochaines élections pour
que ça se règle
monsieur la fronière dites-vous à
plusieurs endroit est dangereux parce
qu'il était trop ambitieux
il voulait trop de pouvoir l'être un
chef de police à part entière avec une
vraie unité de police mais en même temps
d'avoir une unité de police forte contre
la collusion ce pas ça qu'on voulait au
québec on a pris la décision en 2011 et
on était en urgence politique de faire
une unité permanente anticorruption et à
l'époque avec le ministre robert dutil
la discussion a été fait en commission
parlementaire sur la pertinence d'un
corps de police ou non et la décision
était rendue que on n'avait pas besoin
d'un corps de police
on avait besoin d'un coordonnateur des
clips dans kate n'était pas assez pour
monsieur la fronière et tout le long du
livre s'est abondamment expliqué tout le
cheminement de l'upac et je remet même
en question aujourd'hui l'utilité de
l'upac
on a des problèmes de climat de travail
depuis 2011 s'est abondamment documenté
après 2017 tout le monde est parti il ya
plus d expertise on se ramasse encore
avec les mêmes problèmes
je pense qu'il va falloir se poser des
questions puis demander à monsieur
legault pourquoi
on n'a pas entendu monsieur la fronière
cantier démissionner c'est à pau
libéraux qui et aux proches de monsieur
lebon en fait c'était personne parce que
démissionner jour d'élection mais
effectivement ne pas entendu monsieur la
fronière mais je reviens ce que vous
dites là à qui ça profiterait monsieur
ouellette si l'upac moore est du pur
bandits quand même non seulement pas
vous savez par les niveaux de service la
sûreté du québec au des enquêteurs
d'ailleurs il ya plus de gens afin
qu'ils soient un corps de police
il y avait plusieurs enquêteurs de la
sûreté du québec qui était prêté à
l'upac
il y avait plusieurs enquêteurs de la
police de montréal qui était prêté à
l'upac de longueuil d'un peu partout et
c'est dans les niveaux de service la
sûreté du québec peut faire toute la
corruption
la police de montréal peut faire toutes
les infractions de malversations dans le
niveau 5
on n'a plus besoin de l'upac monsieur
roy oui mais mais pourquoi pas avoir un
corps de police
aguerri avec une expertise en col blanc
et c'est pour me dis pourquoi pas dans
le fond à quoi ça nous dérange si on est
sonné droit ça nous dérange pas non
absolument je suis d'accord avec vous
mais vous savez monsieur roy les
enquêtes de du pack sont générés par des
dénonciations so fun monsieur la
fresnière décidé il ya certains de
partir l'an km/h sûrs et certains 300
témoins plus tard toujours pas de
résultats si tu casses que sais-tu parce
que c'est trop compliqué sais-tu parce
qu'on n'a pas l'expertisé la corruption
s'est tue parce que on n'a pas les lois
qu'il y aurait jamais personne qui s'est
plaint mais c'est en est un très bel
exemple
ce qui m'amène à vous demandez pas ce
que vous dites dans votre livre à la fin
le parti libéral n'est pas content oui
il ya eu des individus qui ont fait du
financement illégal
mais de façon générale le parti donc
d'après vous est ce que ma chérie un
jour va aboutir à quelque chose ou pas
un précédent quête 300 témoins je pense
que vous vous avez votre réponse
monsieur ouellet c'est tout a cramé jeu
je veux continuer un petit peu pas
longtemps l'avenir comment vous voyez
votre année là vous avez été expulsé du
caucus j'habitais il eut d'abord pour
rappeler aux gens ils avaient été vus
d'enchaîner d une autre fois mais vous
avez été exclu du caucus parce que vous
avez envoyé des infos à la cac
mais non non comment ça non sur pietro
perrino vous avez envoyé monsieur
legault le répète aujourd'hui de
renvoyer des informations à la cac
monsieur legault pas lu le livre
commence et quand monsieur legault
aurait dû livre il y en a une demi-page
monsieur legault surtout à 136 pages
monsieur roy
j'ai rien à me reprocher et je vous le
dis publiquement ce soir là vous
regardant je ne suis pas une source de
la cac
il ya des informations qui rentrent il
ya des choses qui rentrent depuis je
voulais dire c'est une des raisons
pourquoi j'écris il ya des choses qui
sont en train de se faire vous allez
avoir dans les prochains jours des
développements par rapport à ce que je
viens de vous dire ok donc monsieur où
elle est ce que je veux dire aux gens
parce que pour l'avoir lu effectivement
c'est vraiment un roman cette histoire
leur avec robert lafrenière d'un côté
martin prud'homme son beau fils de
l'autre une promiscuité dans le monde
policier on sait plus qui est bon qui
est méchant
il ya beaucoup de noms d'air vous vous
n'avez beaucoup de nos ya programmant
vous écorchez pas après ça n'en livre
mais bon les gens jugeront mais c'est
intéressant
c'est une pièce de plus dans ce poison
l'extraordinaire et comme citoyen je te
faisait connaître le pays arrive avec
des conclusions d'une enquête sur ce qui
vous est arrivé puis surtout le rêve
merci nous avons parlé monsieur one est
on se reparle
merci monsieur roy aura